so I've now beaten Li of P twice with
the second playthrough being on new game
plus I also didn't use any summons on
either playthrough so I feel like I've
seen enough of the game to do a full
ranking of all the bosses and this video
is focused on ranking them from easiest
all the way up to the most difficult
throughout the game you'll encounter a
variety of different boss types and one
of those types is the stalkers these are
very similar to the hunters from
bloodborne but I think they're much
easier overall it could be my experience
with bloodborne factoring in here but on
my first playthrough I think I maybe
only died once or twice to them through
the entire game the easiest one is
probably the Mad donkey who comes in at
number 25 on our list and he also
happens to be the first stalker boss you
run into maybe these fights are a bit
tough for newcomers but as soon as you
learn how to effectively use the
backstab mechanic you can completely
destroy this guy and even if you can't
nail the backstab consistently you're
fine to just strafe around them until
there's an opening or even just hold
your block button and then get your
health back when you attack of course if
you're good at the perfect guard
mechanic the fight is even easier and
that's true for every fight on this list
and I think maybe one of the reasons
that so many people are saying this game
is harder than the souls games because
hitting that perfect guard is incredibly
important for so many of the bosses on
this list by the time you reach our next
boss you're pretty leveled up and should
also have a much better understanding of
the game black cat has a long spear to
hit you from range so it can help if you
have something to match that distance he
does a lot of poking and jabbing with
the spear but you can pretty easily jump
aside or move away when he tries to hit
you he is quick and has a lot of side to
side movement but there are plenty of
breaks in between which means there's a
lot of time to attack and I should point
out his difficulty drops to zero if you
choose to give him a gold coin fruit
that's right you can avoid this fight
entirely if you want I didn't fight him
at all on my first playthrough but even
on new game plus he really wasn't a
problem at all here we have another
optional stalker boss in the atoned if
you have the stalker's promise which you
get from another boss you can show her
the stalker's greeting and pass without
a fight if you do nothing though she'll
attack and the fight begins she wields a
big pickaxe and can make your weapon
weaker over time thanks to Decay which
is one of the more annoying status
effects in the game she's fast but her
moves are pretty standard if you're far
away she'll eventually run in to attack
you and this is going to give you a
chance to get behind her for some hits
of your own including a powerful
backstab I didn't fight her at all in my
first playthrough but did on New Game
Plus and was still able to handle the
fight pretty easily speaking of the
stalker's greeting the character you
need to fight to get this is the
Survivor he's pretty quick and has a
long sword that can hit you from decent
range it also doesn't help that you
fight him in a pretty tight space it's
really more about dealing with a small
room here as the fight plays out
similarly to the other stalker fights
you can also get those backstabs on him
for Big Time damage which can help in
the fight pretty quickly another
optional stalker boss you meet in a very
tight space is the ow doctor he uses a
bone cutting saw and a dagger the saw is
faster than it looks plus he also does a
lot of jump attacks again moving around
in a small room and keeping him in front
of you is key to this fight of course
you can circle behind him for the
backstabs and this General side to side
movement is pretty helpful for avoiding
his combos too there's also this
annoying pillar that you have to contend
with but there are some weapons like the
puppet Ripper for example that allow you
to use it to your advantage if you're
too far away he might throw his dagger
plus he does have an unblockable attack
that you'll need to be ready for next we
have puppet of the future and you'll
encounter a handful of these throughout
the game honestly this is one I don't
even consider a boss I'm including it on
the list because running into one does
trigger the boss Health meter but he
really just feels like a very large
standard enemy the first time you run
into one he's in this pool of corruption
so you're better off skipping the fight
at first until you find a lever that's
in a nearby Workshop this is going to
clear up that corruption and make the
fight much easier the puppet's not very
quick he does have strong attacks but as
long as you don't get too greedy this
should be an easy fight everything is
telegraphed well ahead of time you can
stay close to its legs or its heels and
just step back when you see him lift it
does take a bit to whittle down his
health but as long as you're patient
this fight isn't any trouble at number
19 we have the Robert weasel boss and
this is one of the first soccer fights
that actually felt a bit challenging
even if it pales in comparison to the
boss is coming up she has this fiery Axe
and some of her attacks can be a little
bit tricky to avoid she also has this
throwing attack which you can guard
against but the timing is a little hard
to predict if she hits you with a
throwing attack she'll almost certainly
Dash in with her axe right after getting
behind her for a backstab is possible
but her quick movement makes that a bit
more challenging than with some of the
other stalkers I did still take her out
on the first try but she was certainly
the first stalker fight that actually
made me sweat a little bit the parade
Master is a giant mechanical puppet that
looks like a circus leader he blocks the
way to hotel crot and is the first main
boss you'll encounter as a result he's
not too crazy difficult don't get me
wrong this is still a soulslike and he
has plenty of attacks that can end the
fight in just a few hits but overall
this fight is a nice boss introduction
to help ease new players into the game
given size the attacks are pretty
predictable he'll charge stomp punch and
smash an effort to take you out for the
first half of the fight you can Dodge
out of the way or even land some perfect
guards to get things started on the
right foot if he goes for the big slam
with his whole body and you're able to
land a perfect guard against it this
opens him up for a flurry of attacks as
it takes him a bit to get back up once
you're halfway through the fight he'll
rip off his own head and use it as a
mace to do even stronger more aggressive
attacks if you time your attacks though
just right and land a few perfect guards
you'll take him out in short order black
cat was lower on our list but his sister
red fox is a different story if you
chose to fight black cat then this fight
with red fox is unavoidable but if you
gave the gold coin fruit you can skip
this fight completely as well the fight
happens near the end of the game in a
long but narrow space just outside
jepetto's prison cell I didn't do this
fight at all on my first playthrough but
I can say on the new game plus
playthrough these attacks hit pretty
hard she fights with a curve saber and
has some pretty quick attacks the combos
can be tough to times just right and at
least on new game plus your health can
just melt away quickly if she finds the
right opening because the area is
somewhat narrow you again have to be
aware of your surroundings and try not
to get backed against the wall it helped
me to be a bit more patient and go for
light attacks instead of trying to
always land the big hit and like all the
other stalkers she can be hit with a
backstab which you should be going for
at every opportunity and for our final
stalker fight on the list we have the
white lady at number 16 she has a pretty
interesting backstory in that she had
dreams of becoming an opera singer you
see she was part of a performing duo
with her sister Adelina a singer that
you can meet elsewhere in the game but
not as a boss fight Adelina lost her
ability to sing due to to the
petrification disease and now her sister
is seeking Revenge as for the fight you
can score a few easy hits right away if
you're ready she's using a Rapier and
attacks quickly with thrusts and slashes
she's pretty good at moving around and
always tries to stay in front of you
which can make backstabs a little bit
more difficult in this fight her moves
are fast and can be tough to avoid
especially when she does a combo she
also has this charge attack that gives
her even more reach so you really have
to start learning to identify that and
be ready for it fortunately this fight
has plenty of space to move around so
you can definitely use that to your
advantage and take time to heal when you
get hit the Walker of Illusions is a
boss that I beat on my first try and I
would probably put him more into the
category of a mini boss instead of a
main boss but he is still required to
progress he has a long sword in one hand
and a dagger in the other which he'll
use to do a series of quick strikes and
slashes often in a combo timing is
everything in this fight if you can land
perfect guards the whole fight becomes
much easier but that's pretty much true
for all the bosses in this game this one
I feel like it's even more important
though because of the close quarters of
course Landing those perfect guards is
easier said than done you do not have to
worry about a second phase here but
halfway through the fight he'll make a
copy that you also have to deal with
fortunately the Clone doesn't have too
much health so I made sure to take that
one out as soon as it appeared like some
of the other fights on our list the
arena does play a key role in how the
fight plays out like I said you're in
pretty Close Quarters here so there
aren't too many chances to escape and
heal if you take too many hits which
makes the perfect guarding that much
more important the corrupted parade
Master is like the parade Master you
meet at the start of the game but now
it's overtaken by corruption which makes
for a slightly more challenging fight
this time he starts with the mace weapon
from the beginning but overall the
attacks are pretty much the same most of
the attacks are with the maze he swings
it around and can do a bunch of hits in
a row the biggest difference now is that
it can inflict Decay and also spawn
additional enemies in the arena not
really sure what these things are called
but they remind me of some corrupted
version of Groot fortunately they're
pretty slow and don't have a lot of
Health but they are another element that
you'll need to account for in the fight
if they do happen to catch you they can
deal a lot of damage so you can't
completely ignore them like before you
should be aggressive in between the
corrupted parade Master's attacks and
there should be multiple stagger
opportunities if you're doing doing that
which of course opens him up for an even
bigger attack the door Guardian is a lot
more intimidating than he actually is
his attacks definitely hit like a truck
and in return it can seem like your
attacks aren't dealing much damage he
uses his fists to punch and smash which
can hit you with the shock status effect
this is the one that makes you lose
stamina so definitely want to watch out
for that the big punches are slow though
so you can usually Dodge or perfect
guard against them the strategy that
worked best for me is to Simply Focus
all my hits on his right leg they don't
do much damage on their own but after a
time you'll get him into a groggy state
and then follow up with that fatal
attack which does massive I mean massive
damage against this guy just outside of
our top 10 we have the scrapped Watchman
he's found in the courtyard of crot City
Hall early in the game and it's likely
he's the first real challenge for most
players the demo they released before
launch actually let you play all the way
up to him and a lot of players found him
pretty difficult to deal with especially
considering how early you run into him
he uses these long arms to attack and
move around he can also jump quickly to
get in close and hit you with his arm
the attacks can seem like they're are
coming from all different directions
especially when you first start going
against him but like all of the bosses
there are patterns and you'll begin to
notice these over time my soul's
experience definitely came into play Big
Time here he gave me some trouble in the
demo but in my first real playthrough I
was ready for him and made it through
quickly you'll start to recognize that
his main go-to combo has him do this
little wind up with his right arm then
another with his left then a big Slam in
the middle you want to try and hit
perfect guards against all three of
these if you can do that you'll have a
nice opening for an attack and may even
stag him in the process and this is also
going to be helpful for another boss
coming up on this list just a bit later
then once he gets into the second half
of the fight he uses more electric
attacks including one that you'll need
to just completely back away to avoid
and I would say that after a few
attempts you should probably have the
timing down as many of these attacks do
have pretty easy to spot tells King's
flame foko is next on our list and this
is one of the bosses that feels really
hard at first but after a bit you
realize he's not too bad at least that's
how it went for me you're in a good
sized Arena here and there there are
also all these pillars that you can use
for cover even if he can take them out
with his charge attack like so many
bosses in Li of though it definitely
pays to be aggressive here there are a
few attacks of his that if you get
behind him you can just avoid those
attacks entirely and just keep attacking
him fok's main attacks are punches and
swings and you should be able to block
or Dodge most of these when he's about
to use his fire moves like shooting
Fireballs or a flamethrower you want to
stay close if you back away he's going
to charge now with all of those fire
attacks he can inflict overheat in fact
there's one attack in particular that
when you see him readying up for it's
best to just get as far away as you can
this also might be one of the first
fights where you'll really want to think
about the other items in your inventory
and just in general I would say in Li of
P don't sleep on the extra items the
shot put can be incredibly helpful not
just in this fight but in many fights
when you get things into a groggy state
if you throw a shot put that is
basically like a heavy attack right
there and will immediately set them up
for a fatal strike for this particular
fight though the attribute purification
ample I think think how you say that
that can be used to immediately remove
overheat so that's one that you might
want to have quick access to taking our
number 10 spot is the first battle you
have with the eldest of the black rabbit
Brotherhood this fight is really all
about fighting multiple enemies at once
you end up doing battle against all four
members of the Brotherhood but in this
fight they attack in sequences instead
of all at once the eldest brother has a
huge blade for his weapon and
heavy-hitting combos to go along with it
the Spin Attack he does can take you out
incredibly fast but it's also one of the
best opportunities to land multiple
perfect guards in a row if you can nail
that timing so as you progress through
the fight the other members kind of take
turns joining in to help out big brother
and I think he definitely gets less
aggressive when they're out on the
battlefield so for me it wasn't too hard
to kind of lure them away take them out
and then go back to fighting the eldest
the mad clown puppet is probably the
most difficult mini boss in the game
you'll find the optional boss near the
Estella Opera House in the Entertainment
District I didn't even know this my
first time theory but I took a chance on
just running past him to see if if I
could reach another checkpoint and
that's exactly what happens in fact you
can skip the fight entirely by running
past him up the stairs and around the
building to hit your next Stargazer even
if you don't want to skip him though
running around like this makes the fight
a bit easier by unlocking that
checkpoint you can refresh your health
and then backtrack to where the clown is
positioned this will let you score at
least a few hits before he really gets
going with those attacks once he does
start attacking though you'll see he has
a variety of different punches including
a really longrange punch that can deal a
ton of damage and even if you block this
with a perfect guard because you're so
far away it's going to be hard to land a
follow-up attack he also has an annoying
Spin Attack and another where he lunges
at you with his stomach which that one
for some reason for me was just really
hard to get a read on it this is
definitely one of those fights where if
you go into it too overconfident you
might be surprised at how many times he
keeps taking you out the Fallen
Archbishop Andreas is another boss fight
that would fit perfectly in bloodborne
he's a massive hulking grotesque
creature who charges at you in different
ways and even uses his tongue for a
whip-like attack by this point in the
game I was really starting to see how
much much easier it made these fights
when I could consistently perfect guard
and this one it did take me a bit to get
all of his attack patterns down but once
I did I tried to land perfect guards at
every opportunity this really helps to
get to that second phase as quickly as
possible also the flame grindstone as
well as the flame Legion arm you can use
those in either phase and they're going
to be pretty helpful I really enjoyed
the mechanic here of phase two of the
fight because now he can attack you from
either side of his body depending on
which side you're on it's almost like
fighting a totally different enemy
because the attacks are so different now
I feel like most people will do what I
tried to do is since you're already
familiar with his b side you want to get
to that side at every opportunity the
attacks they're a little bit different
but similar enough that I prefer to go
to that side as soon as I had the chance
there are a few moments when he'll try
to get you to face the other side but I
just kept sprinting to that Beast side
as much as I could once I started using
that strategy it wasn't long before I
got the victory at number seven we have
our second runin with the black rabbit
Brotherhood this time you need to beat
all of them to win and they each have a
full health bar fortunately they don't
have much Health Plus you can also
backstab each of them so I went for that
as much as possible on their own they're
really not very tough the difficulty of
this fight is in the various status
effects that they can inflict and try to
make sure that you keep them isolated
for those one-on-one fights the battle
Maniac has a red scarf and uses a sword
plus he also has fire attacks that can
cause overheat he always seemed to be
the most aggressive one in my fights but
that could just be random I'm not sure
the youngest wears a hood and uses two
swords she kicks and slashes but can
also hit you with Decay which again that
is really one of the most annoying
status of effects to deal with so for
sure I get why a lot of guides recommend
that you try and take her out first
entric is the one with the bucket on his
head and a long spear he does electric
damage and I have to say he was the
easiest one in all of my fights the real
key in this fight is taking out one of
them as soon as possible then whittling
down the health of the other two until
they're both close to death basically
you want to get them to the point where
you can take out both of them in very
rapid succession this is going to make
it so you can face the eldest brother in
a one-on-one situation you see he he is
actually triggered to resurrect once
you've eliminated two of the others so
what you want to avoid is a situation
where you're having to face off against
one of the original Three Plus the
eldest brother at the same time once I
figured this out it made the fight much
easier as the eldest on his own is
pretty close to how he was in that first
fight with most of the same attacks the
green monster of the swamp and his
second phase the puppet devouring green
monster land at number six for this list
you'll encounter this required boss in
the baron swamp it mostly uses its hands
or I Les I guess you would call these to
attack he's got swipes and smashes but
he also has these Decay inflicting
attacks and those can be pretty
difficult to dodge if you're too far
away he may do this charge attack which
can at first seem overwhelming I quickly
learned though that you can perfect
guard against this which of course gives
you a big opening to attack in fact if I
ever needed some breathing room I didn't
mind this attack at all I would actually
Retreat on purpose to try and bait that
attack out cuz once I figured out the
timing that was one that I could pretty
consistently get the perfect guard on
now one that I could not get
consistently is this move where where he
burrows underground and then leaps back
out after a time you can kind of see him
approaching rolling underneath the
ground the best thing I could figure out
was to roll back at the last possible
second just before I knew it was about
to LEAP out but even that didn't seem to
work 100% of the time I also used a lot
of fire in this fight and once again
aggression is the name of the game here
the first phase does have a full health
bar but once you take him out you move
to phase two where he puts on the armor
of a previous boss the scrapped Watchman
yep remember I said it was going to be
important to learn his attacks you see
in doing so he actually takes on some of
that boss's attacks but now with a few
additions thanks to all those tentacles
underneath he can take these really big
jumps now but he still does a lot of
punching and clawing but fortunately one
of the attacks that he brings over from
that Watchman fight is that little
windup move the one where he winds up
right winds up left and then does the
big Slam in the middle I often found
this was the best opportunity to get
some big damage on him provided of
course that my timing was on point with
those perfect guards now one slight
difference at the end of that attack
this time is he's going to throw in this
little tentacle sweep it extends outward
at the very end of that combo right
after the big slam but you should be
able to avoid that by staying directly
in front of him when you set up for the
perfect guard the king of Puppets is one
of my favorite boss fights in the entire
game this fight just has everything you
want to see in a good boss fight you'll
run into him inside the Estella opera
house and the fight starts with this
giant mechik puppet he uses his long
arms to attack often in these big
sweeping motions and with those arms he
has a really long reach again I found it
best to stay up close and aggressive as
much as possible once the giant puppet
is destroyed we move to the second part
of the fight and see there was actually
a human inside Romeo the king of Puppets
he uses a scythe which has a good amount
of range on it plus just a wider array
of attacks in general he's now more
aggressive outside the mech he has quick
movement and can even get away fast if
you try and chase him down with too much
aggression when I first ran into Romeo I
was trying to perfect guard everything
like always if you can do this
consistently it's absolutely the way to
go however at this point in the game I
don't know I was just not able to
consistently pull it off some of these
attacks in the second phase were just a
little bit too tricky once I stopped
trying to perfect guard everything
though and started using more Dodges
specifically left Dodges the fight
became so much easier he has this really
strong move in the second phase with a
quick series of fiery attacks but even
these can mostly be avoided with a few
Dodges to the left after a few tries
against him I definitely felt like this
fight might take me a while to finish
but shifting my strategy to more Dodgers
just made the second half so much easier
the next fight is one I didn't feel like
should be that hard none of his attacks
here or anything all that out of the
ordinary but the truth is simply that
champion Victor hits like a tank and
he's built like a tank for such a large
hulking figure his attacks are really
quick plus they aren't easy to predict
it took me getting grabbed and slammed
several times before I noticed he always
says something before going for that
grab attack which can just absolutely
shred your health if you get caught by
it and if you're going for perfect
guards and you miss too many times it's
easy to quickly run out of heals against
him on the plus side though this is one
of the few fights in the game where I
thought that the first phase was much
harder than the second once you get to
phase two he'll remove his attachments
but still uses punches and charge
attacks he does seem a bit slower in
this phase though and I didn't feel like
there was enough new in that second
phase to make it more difficult and by
the time I actually was reaching that
phase consistently I had such a good
handle on phase one that it really
didn't give me too much trouble Simon
Manis awakened God now this is a really
interesting one here at number three on
our list you see I actually had two very
different experiences with this guy my
first playthrough and then my new game
plus playthrough if I based things only
on my first go I would have had him
ranked much lower you see I made it to
his second phase in just my very first
attempt and then beat the boss on my
second try I could see how he could
cause people some problems but I just
didn't understand some of the other list
I was seeing out there that had him
ranked pretty high that second attempt
when I beat him honestly I think I just
got lucky I don't even think I had
enough time to see all of his attacks
because meeting up with him again in New
Game Plus was a completely different
story I died on this one again and again
and again in the first phase he uses
this giant mace to swing at you it's
pretty slow but because he's so big
there's a lot of range on these swings
again calling back to my experience
playing bloodborne this boss felt like
he'd be right at home there in the
awakened God phase which is his second
phase he gains new powers like these
powerful wind gust he can summon golden
beams that hit you with disruption and
this disruption is the worst status
effect in the game it's worse than Decay
you see disruption is the one where if
the meter heals completely you die
instantly no matter how much health you
have so you have to keep moving and
dodging but then while he shoot Sho
these beams he'll very often start
hitting you with other attacks while
they're still raining down on you even
when I could make it to his second phase
consistently on new game plus he would
just overwhelm me with all these
different magical attacks some of which
can hit you from anywhere in the arena
then you combine that with this attack
where he flies High into the air
sometimes at such an angle that the
camera freaks out and you can't even see
him it just makes for a really tough
phase too and on New Game Plus these
attacks at this late game stage are
hitting so hard that you need to heal
basically after you get hit even once
the nameless puppet is technically an
optional boss fight which is a bit
strange considering that it will likely
be the final boss in the game for most
people after you defeat Simon you'll
take the elevator down and meet up with
jepetto oh and these are some pretty big
story spoilers coming up but hopefully
you wouldn't have watched this far if
you were worried about spoilers so
jepetto asked for your heart to
resurrect his son Carlo but as long as
you've told at least a few lies
throughout the game you'll have the
option to refuse this starts your battle
with the nameless puffet he fights with
a long sword and uses a series of
swinging and slashing attacks
unsurprisingly these combos come in
Rapids ession and only with time and
memorization will you be able to perfect
guard against them if you stay too far
away the puppet will Dash and follow up
with a quick attack also he actually has
the ability to heal during this first
phase I've heard he can do this up to
two times I only ever saw him do it once
though like most of the other phase 2
fights though this is when the
difficulty really ramps up now the
puppet is even faster can wield two
swords and has attacks that hit from
even further away it's more aggressive
in this phase and charges at you
frequently this is also a great
opportunity to use the per Perfection
grindstone which is the one that gives
you guaranteed perfect guards for a
short time if you never use this
grindstone you're missing out it is
incredibly op even though it only lasts
a short time it enables you to perfect
guard against any attack by simply
holding the block button there were also
two amulets that really made a big
difference for me especially when I was
going through my new game plus run the
Assassin's amulet which increases your
critical attack as well as the puppet
destroyer's amulet which increases the
damage you do against puppets like Simon
this fight was way more challenging on
the New Game Plus run just because of
how much harder these attacks Hit And
depending on your defense and overall
health I mean there are a few attacks
that can take you out in one hit at
number one and this probably isn't a
surprise to anyone who's played the game
it's laxia the complete what's funny is
not only do I think this is the toughest
boss it's also my favorite fight in the
entire game and if you think about it
that's a really difficult thing to do to
make a boss fight they can punish you
time and time again but at the same time
you still respect and even enjoy the
battle laasia starts the fight wearing
full body armor and she carries a
massive sword which can deal electric
shock damage she swings The Sword in a
variety of different ways like chopping
down and adding an electric shock at the
end she also has regular sword moves
like swinging sweeping and slashing and
because the sword is so massive all of
these attacks have quite a bit of range
to them and while it's true for several
fights in this game this is by far the
most important fight to learn her attack
patterns and land those perfect guards
you can make the first phase of this
fight so much easier once you land them
consecutively AET also helps out a ton
as it can take out the shield in just a
couple of hits phase two though is when
the real fight begins first we get this
gorgeous cut scene showing laasia
removing the armor and changing her
sword now she moves faster and doesn't
give you much time at all to even
breathe she kicks off this phase with a
flurry of long range lightning attacks
which you can deflect back at her with a
perfect guard this is like old school
Ocarina of Time but on steroids right
here then she ends that series of moves
with this lightning quick dive bomb
that's incredibly difficult to perfect
guard against she's so far away and
there are so many other things just kind
of FL flashing in Your Vision it's hard
to see when she starts the dive to
actually know when you need to guard I
only guarded against this successfully a
handful of times that is until I started
saving my perfection grindstone for the
very beginning of phase 2 this helped me
to consistently start Phase 2 with a
good amount of damage plus not taking
any damage myself as much as I love all
the special effects and that's part of
what makes this fight so great all the
lightning around you at the same time I
do think it makes things a little bit
harder to see harder to know exactly
when you should perfect guard then again
maybe that's just my excuse for not
being able to get good against the
deathly quick attacks in the second
phase because even with getting that
solid Head Start thanks to the
grindstone this fight took me a
ridiculous number of tries to finally
get by and all the while I never ended
up hating to fight or feeling like it
was too cheap I'm happy to say New Game
Plus was a completely different story
and it only took me a handful of tries
to take her out so I must have learned
something from all those failed attempts
my first go round I'm planning to make a
full video about my run to get the
platinum trophy in this game once that's
ready I'll link it here on the left side
of the screen until then you can check
out my trophy hunt for Spider-Man M
moral which is certainly a much easier
game than Li a PE as always thank you
all so much for watching I'll talk to
you again soon